good morning everyone
madam madam president dear ursula
this day is a beautiful day and it's uh
it's a day which is ready for for
celebration celebration after
a lot of hard work together
with the minister presidents of the
regions and of
the communities we are particularly
pleased to
welcome you here in uh in brussels
this morning in this building until a
few years ago
in this part of the building you would
only see people who were the
railroad workers in a building which is
a historic building a victor orta
building today in 2021 every day
more than a thousand people come here
entrepreneurs
coders who are immersing them into this
new
digital digital world and they're also
mingling of course with commuters and
europeans who are connecting
through uh through brussels thanks to
the
26 different digital schools that we
have in this building 26
different uh schools b central is today
in europe the largest digital education
hub in in all of europe and it's a great
source of pride to welcome you here um
i don't think there could be a better
symbolic place to welcome you talking
about the transformation of our economy
into an economy for the future
plans
please
foreign
you
the last the past weeks and months have
also
been very intensive on the side of
discussions that we've had with the
european uh commission
ursula would like to thank you and thank
your teams for the um
extremely intense cooperation that we've
had
um you have really pushed us and your
teams really have pushed us
to um making the best out of this and to
really coming with
the best a country can can offer and i
would really would like to to thank you
for this let's call it motivational role
that the commission has played towards
us
is
madam president i give you the floor yes
thank you so much prime minister the
alexandre
president it's a pleasure to be here and
thank you very much for the very warm
welcome
here and i have to say i'm really
impressed what i've seen
in this building this is amazing to see
those young people
with all this motivation from all walks
of
life and as far as i understand you can
just come if you're motivated enough
and you can be a programmer within seven
months if the motivation is
there the teaching skills are here and
um this is amazing to see that so i
could really feel
let's say the passion of these people
working here and thanks very much for
that
experience indeed we have gone through
very tough times the last 15 months in
the pandemic
and now it's about recovery now it's
about building up resilience
and one of our main cornerstones is next
generation you
our recovery plan for europe but
it is much more than recovery it will
shape our continent for decades ahead
we will be investing through next
generation eu
more in digitization than ever before
we will make the european green deal a
reality
with these investments and we will be
equipping our societies and our
economies
to be stronger and to be more resilient
next generation eu is worth 800 billion
euro in today's prices it is the largest
recovery package
in europe since the marshall plan and it
is a recovery that
europe needs now and it will need it for
the future so
indeed i'm very happy to announce that
today the european commission has given
green light
to belgium's recovery and resilience
plan
it follows indeed an excellent
cooperation between our authorities i
very much thank you for that it follows
a thorough assessment through the
commission
and if you look at the reforms and the
investment
i am sure it foresees that it will
accelerate
the green and the digital transition in
belgium but
of course also for the benefit of europe
nearly 50 of the plan will
support green objectives and it will
help protect our climate
just to take a few examples you will be
investing
in large-scale energy renovation as we
know 40
of the energy is going through buildings
so that's a main source of greenhouse
gas emissions
if we invest there for insulation or
modern heating and cooling system it's a
big step forward
it will invest in clean mobility in the
deployment of new
green public buses and of
tens of thousands of electric charging
stations
we've been speaking about that how
important it is to have
the modern uh mobility the clean
mobility
and i'm very glad to see that this plan
also heavily invests in the protection
of belgium's beautiful nature and
beautiful biodiversity so
thank you very much for putting this
emphasis there too
but as we've visited witness today here
in this building too
the belgium plan will dedicate a
significant
part to our other landmark goal and that
is digitalization
you are already a front runner in this
area
and indeed rightly so you should take
pride in it
this is outstanding and now you will
dedicate 25
of the belgian plan to digitalization i
think next generation you will give the
boost
to maintain your leadership in that
field
with investments in fiber in digital
equipment for schools
in digital skills for all and here we
saw a brilliant example so this
is the right way to go in short
the plan clearly meets the demanding
criteria
we have jointly established the reforms
it contains
will improve the efficiency and the
sustainability of public finances
and they will make belgium's education
system
more inclusive more digital and help
reach our objective of an 80
employment rate by 2030. therefore
i'm glad to give green light to this
ambitious far-sighted
plan the commission's approval is an
important milestone
for the disbursement of close to 6
billion euros
over the next years so what is needed
now
is the approval by the council within
the next four weeks
and then in july we can start together
and it is now with confidence that i
hand over to you alexander on behalf of
the european commission
the proof that this plan has been
that this plan has been
i think we are now open for some uh some
some questions
uh mrs von the lion giving money is
easy of course but i can imagine that
you want
your money back um
it's also my money but when do you want
it back
we are with next generation eu um
investing heavily in the future and we
have called it next generation you
because you're right we're raising money
at the capital market
in a large large sum and therefore the
investment has to be
future proof it is investing in fighting
climate change
in keeping our nature and biodiversity
and it is investing in the digitization
for us is important and therefore we
called it next generation eu
that we mitigate the risks for the next
generation and that we open the door
for opportunities for the next
generation
first to both of you there was the first
issuance of eu bonds last week
and there was a high demand even seven
times higher than the offer
i think you said in italy that this was
an exceptional response to an
exceptional crisis but
do you both think that maybe this way to
finance our budget
should continue in the future and not be
a one-shot
minister
economics that confirms
so it is an exceptional response to an
exceptional crisis because for the very
first time
we are raising this amount of money
together
as on the european level as 27
and you're right when we were raising
the capital last week on the financial
markets
we could just see the trust and the
confidence
in this european union because it was so
heavily oversubscribed which is always
a signal for trust and confidence and
now
it's our common responsibility and i'm
very glad to see you here it's our
common
responsibility really to make it happen
we have to prove that we are worth this
investment and the trust and the
confidence
and therefore for me the main job now is
together
with the leaders implementation
implementation implementation
and make sure that we are worth the
confidence
foreign
um how severe will the commission be
when
controlling if belgium reaches its
milestones or will you be rather
lenient i have also a second question
last week prime minister the crow
said that the eu is not the cash machine
referring to the situation in hungary
and poland
when will the european commission start
applying the rule
of law conditionality mechanism and
will you act upon the demand of 40
member states
to refer hungary to the european court
of justice regarding the
the law that was approved last week yes
so
um if i take your last question first
the hungarian bill is a shame
and i've instructed my responsible
commissioners
to write a letter to the hungarian
authorities
concerning or expressing our legal
concerns before the bill
enters into force this
bill clearly discriminates against
people
on the basis of their sexual orientation
and it goes against all the values the
fundamental values
of the european union and this is human
dignity
it is equality and is the human
fundamental rights so we will not
compromise on these
principles and i have said it before and
i want to repeat it
i strongly believe in a european union
that is clear that where
you where you are who you want to be
and i strongly believe in a european
union where you are free
to love whom you want
and i believe in a european union that
embraces diversity this is the
foundation of our values
so i will use all the powers of the
commission to ensure
that the rights of all eu citizens
are guaranteed whoever you are
and wherever you live
and on the uh on the other question of
the milestones and the targets
we have for every member state
milestones and targets in place
because we agreed it's a very short time
we have to be very efficient
and it has to be very clear that there
is the delivery so the implementation
on the spot so that we can disperse the
different
tranches so every member state will be
treated the same
it's a tough regime but uh we deserve it
to to be tough with each other because
it's for the next generation
good well um i thank you for your uh for
your attendance
and i thank you for um for the questions
huh